[Applaudissements]
la parole est un
à notre collègue Laurent Duplomb pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
je m'adresse à tous les ministres tant
le sujet nous concerne tous
savez-vous que la présidente de la
Commission européenne a autorisé le 3
janvier dernier un nouvel aliment
savez-vous que ce nouvel aliment est une
farine partiellement dégraissée
incorporez dans de multiples recettes
savez-vous que depuis hier vous pouvez
trouver cette farine sans informations
claire du consommateur dans les pins
biscuits sauce plats transformés pizza
confiserie ou pâtes et j'en passe et des
meilleurs enfin savez-vous que cette
farine partiellement dégraissée est
faite avec des acheteurs domesticus
entier broyés en poudre alors madame et
monsieur mesdames et messieurs les
ministres savez-vous ce qu'est
l'acheteur domesticus
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre d'agriculture de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur féno
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs oui monsieur le
sénateur je crois que c'est un insecte
et donc c'est bien la question vous
voulez poser c'est de savoir d'abord
pour dire que pardon de vous le dire il
n'est pas nouveau y compris depuis très
longtemps que dans un certain nombre de
pays on puisse se nourrir d'insectes ce
n'est pas en soi on peut avoir des goûts
différents moi compris mais c'est une
réalité deuxième élément ça participe
tout à fait d'une réglementation
européenne qui a été autorisée
simplement la réglementation européenne
exige monsieur le sénateur c'est qu'on
mentionne la nature du produit en
l'occurrence pour ce cet insecte la
question de l'allergénéité des uns et
des autres donc il faut qu'on soit
vigilant sur la mention dans les
produits qui seront dedans disant qu'il
y a un produit qui peut être allergène
en l'occurrence cet insecte troisième
élément on travaille au niveau européen
globalement essayer d'harmoniser les
choses et c'est mieux que ça soit au
niveau européen que chaque pays décide
de commercialiser telle ou tel autre et
donc c'est ça sur lequel on a besoin de
travailler ça nécessite aussi et nous
avons besoin de continuer à renforcer à
nos frontières européennes mais aussi au
niveau national la surveillance
sanitaire parce qu'il y a toujours des
gens qui essayent de déroger aurait que
nous nous fixions au niveau européen ça
existe dans le sujet agricole et
sanitaire comme d'un bien d'autres
sujets donc il faut qu'on y travaille
qu'on continue à avancer mais
reconnaissons que les mesures qui sont
prises elles vivent plutôt à protéger à
informer le consommateur à protéger le
cas échéant l'environnement et donc
c'est celui-là dessus qu'il faut qu'on
travaille sans travailler sur des
questions distorsion de concurrence ça
me permet un dernier mot monsieur le
sénateur il me semble que sur ces sujets
il faut qu'on travaille justement au
niveau européen rien ne s'épuise on en a
parlé dans un autre exemple tout à
l'heure que d'avoir des dispositions qui
s'appliquent simplement sur le sol
français qui ne s'applique pas au niveau
européen donc la bataille elle est
d'abord européenne et c'est là-dessus
qu'il faut qu'on continue à travailler
monsieur Duplomb
monsieur le ministre comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là à devoir
consommer des grillons de la même
famille que les sauterelles ou les
criquets alors que la France est le pays
de la gastronomie et des terroirs
comment pouvez-vous laisser faire cela
alors que vous n'avez de cesse de nous
parler d'une alimentation saine et
durable d'agroécologie et de circuits
courts saine et durable cette farine ne
l'est pas même la Commission ne garantit
pas l'absence de problèmes sanitaires
contrairement à ce que vous venez de
dire où est l'agroécologie avec
l'élevage hors sol de millions de
grillons dans des bâtiments industriels
et que dire des circuits courts alors
que cette poudre de Grillon est importée
du Vietnam cette Commission européenne
qui cède au lobby antiviande et qui sape
notre agriculture et notre culture
gastronomique je n'en veux plus
soutenant plutôt la farine de blé 16
plutôt que la farine de Grillon
soutenant le sucre français plutôt que
les insectes d'Asie nous ne pouvons pas
accepter de faire manger à leur insu des
insectes aux Français ceux qui
souhaitent manger des grillons sur le
ministre je les invite à venir les
manger directement dans mes prés ils
seront nature entier nombre broyés et
non transformés et pour tous les autres
je leur conseille de constituer que de
continuer à manger une bonne côte de
bœuf
[Applaudissements]